Welcome, everyone.
Thanks for being here.
I get to talk to you about
a package called censored.
It's a new tidymodels package for survival models.
And when people hear
survival analysis,
they often think of
situations and data like this.
And I mean, it's called
survival analysis for a reason.
Most examples are
indeed of the category time
to death.
That is not the only
context in which
you might encounter
censored data and hence
a need for survival models.
I came across my favorite
example for censored data:
Before I joined RStudio, I
was working at a data science
consultancy and one
of my colleagues
chatted to me about
his latest project.
And that involved the
newspaper company,
which wanted to know how
many copies they should
deliver to various outlets.
And he was sort of musing that
if there are any copies left,
at the end of the
day, they would
know how many had been taken and
what the demand for the paper
was.
If there were none left,
they would also still know
how many were taken,
but they wouldn't really
know what the demand was and how
many more could have, would have been
taken if they hadn't run out.
So in that case, their
observation of the newspaper
demand
is actually censored.
It's capped at the number
of papers that they provided.
So the stats nerd in me
grinned and was like,
I suggest you look
at survival analysis.
And now I get to tell you
basically the same thing, too.
So if you have data of this
format where you're observing
something until an event,
be that time to
death or newspapers
taken until demand saturation,
and you may or may not
actually observe that event.
Please use a survival
analysis! That
is designed to take both of
these aspects into account.
So if you take that
data and shove it
into a regular regression
model and model
a time or the demand without
taking that event indicator
into account, you're treating
the observations as complete
when in fact, they may
just be incomplete.
And if you're just dropping all
of your censored observations
and model the rest, you're
also throwing away information
and you're treating these
observations as missing
while they are actually
just incomplete.
So survival analysis is an
important field of modeling
and we're extending support
for it in tidymodels.
The first milestone in this
are the models themselves:
to be able to specify them,
fit them, and predict with them.
And you may well
be aware that R has
an abundance of riches in the
different models contributed
by different people.
And it also has nearly
the same abundance
of riches in interfaces
to these models.
And as you just heard, tidymodels
wants to make it effective,
safe and ergonomic for you.
Part of that is to provide you
with a consistent interface.
THe aspect of tidymodels that takes
care of a consistent interface
for models themselves
is parsnip.
It's designed to
give you consistency,
both in how you specify
and fit the model.
And how you predict
and what you get back.
So you don't have to remember
function names, argument names
across different
packages, whether or not
you get a vector back or
a matrix or a data frame.
And what that type
of prediction was
called in this particular
package you're using.
And the thing I'm really
here to talk about
is censored, which is a
parsnip extension package
for survival models.
So I'll be talking about how
these design ideas play out
and marry with survival analysis.
Let's get to that first part
to specify and fit models.
In parsnip, you need three
elements to specify your model.
So for one, the model
type. In the example here,
it's a random forest.
And you need a
computational engine.
That's what you use
to fit the model.
In my example here that's
the ranger package.
Often that's one of various R packages.
It can also be a tool
outside of R, like stan
if you have a Bayesian
model you want to fit.
And the third element to a
parsnip model specification
is the mode.
A random forest you can use for
regression or classification.
So you need to
specify that here.
And these three elements.
They are very
consistent in parsnip.
So they will also
show up in censored.
So what is actually
new in censored?
Well, we had to
make a few additions.
For one, we have
a new model type
called proportional hazards
to let you fit everyone's
favorite Cox model.
Second of all, we
have a new mode
to distinguish censored
regression from regression.
And thirdly, you
probably guessed
it, several new engines
to existing models.
So with that censored
covers parametric models,
semi-parametric models
and tree-based models
for survival analysis.
And the last point that
I want to mention here
is that we have a
formula interface
for all of these models.
Most of the engines
do that already.
The glmnet package sort
of famously does not.
But we let you interact
with that through a formula
interface, and
that includes a way
to specify stratification.
And that's all sort of abstract.
And I wanted to
have a data example.
Sadly, I do not have access
to that newspaper data.
But I bring you
dolphins and whales.
So these are dolphins and whales
living in captivity in the US,
whether they've been
captured or rescued
or were born in captivity.
It's originally a Tidy
Tuesday data set all the way
from The Pudding.
And we have the response
age in the first column.
How old that dolphin is
or was. If event is zero
the dolphin or
whale is still alive.
We know the species, the sex
and how many times
this animal was
transferred between different
facilities in the US.
So if you want to
go fit that brand
new model, the proportional
hazards model in tidymodels,
we need censored and we need the
proportional hazards function.
And then we can add an engine.
I'm going to go with the
very classic survival package
here as the way
to fit this model.
We're going to add the mode.
That's the new censored
regression mode.
And with that, I have
the specification.
This is not fit yet.
If I want to apply it to
data, I have a fit function.
And that's where the formula
interface comes into play.
Your response is typically a
Surv object on the left hand
side of the formula.
And you want to
add stratification.
You can do that like you would
do in the survival package
and add a strata term
into the formula.
You're looking at
this and saying, well,
that's a bunch of lines
of code for a model.
That is indeed true.
So if you work with the
survival package directly,
that's all a little
bit condensed.
Just the modeling
function, the formula
and the data that sort of
does specification and fit all
rolled into one.
And that's great.
Where censored comes more
into play is if you want to
use something else in addition
to try it out and move
between different models.
So if we want to go from the
standard proportional hazards
model to a regularized
version of that model,
I'm going to move all
of the code to the left
and start doing that with the
glmnet package on the right.
That one has no formula
interface, as I mentioned.
So you need to make
your response matrix,
a predictor matrix.
I'm doing that with
model.matrix here.
And if you want to
include stratification,
you need to stratify
your response
and then you're ready to go.
I put it into glmnet. Remember
to set the family to Cox.
Otherwise, you're
fitting a different model.
And give it a penalty
parameter, lambda.
So of course, this is doable.
But the code looks
quite different
and it's quite a lot of work
to go from one to another.
And we want to make
that aspect easier.
So obviously the next
code is a little boring.
You can take the bit that
we already had for censored.
And copy it over.
And then the main thing you
change is what engine you set.
One is the survival package.
One is glmnet.
And the other thing
you want to change
is the penalty parameter
because it's glmnet,
but the rest is the same.
So we don't have to fiddle
with the data structure here.
We can still use a
formula interface.
And if you want to switch
to yet another type
the tagline for that is kind
of "more models, same syntax".
So you might swap out your
model type for a boosted tree
and set the engine to mboost
and you're ready to go.
And that applies to the rest.
We have in censored, for that
new mode censored regression,
the parametric models
in the survival_reg
function, proportional
hazards for semi-parametric
and then the tree
based models are
decision trees, random forests,
bagged trees and boosted trees.
And that's the section on
specifying and fitting.
And the next one is
obviously predicting.
And in the tidymodels framework,
we give you a little guarantee
that your predictions
will always be inside a tibble.
And the column
names and types are
unsurprising and
predictable, and the number
of rows in new_data and
the output are the same.
So what's new then?
The answer is new prediction types.
One of them for survival
analysis is the survival time.
So I'm just taking the
first three rows here
from my data set to predict them
adding an NA in the first row
just to mix things up a little.
And you can get a prediction
of the survival time
by using the predict function
and setting type to time
and you get a tibble back.
The column will always be
dot pred underscore time
and it will have three rows
because you put three rows in.
So if you have a missing
value, it will have an NA
rather than miraculously
disappear on you.
And the other big new type
for survival predictions
is the survival probability.
That is always calculated
at a point in time.
So here in this example,
I'm setting type survival.
And I want the
survival probability
at age ten, 15, 20 and
40 years for the dolphin or whale
that I'm looking at.
And what do you get back?
It's still a tibble
that has three
rows, for the 3 observations.
But we've asked for four time points.
So this is actually
a list column
and it has little tibbles
stashed inside of it.
If we want to look at one of them,
we can pull it out.
And then we see the
column that gives us
the information about the time
point that we're predicting on
and the probability, except for
in this case, it's an NA. But
if you look at the other one,
you do get actual probabilities.
and.
This does not return you
a classical Surv object or survfit
object.
If you do want to access
the full survival curve,
you can pretty easily just dial
up the number of time points
you ask for.
So here I'm asking for survival
probability predicted at age
one all the way through 80.
And then I can unnest that thing to
stack all the little tibbles
underneath each other.
And I'm squeezing in the mutate
to be still able to tell which
rows belong to which dolphin.
And that gives you a data
set that is ready for ggplot.
And you can easily do your
visualization of the survival
curve with a geom_step.
So to recap.
The prediction
types that are new.
are "time" for survival
time and "survival"
for survival probability.
These are available for all of
the models that are in censored
and depending on the engine
you might also be able to
predict the hazard, the quantile
of the event time distribution
or the linear predictor
if your model has one.
You do not have to do
any of the data prep
for a matrix interface.
You don't have to pad your
results at the right place
if there's a missing
value in there.
And you also don't
have to do the legwork
to go from a survival curve
to predicted probability
at any given time point.
And the summary of this
all is basically: censored
is a consistent interface
for survival models.
It gives you
consistency in how you
specify and fit and consistency
in how you predict
and what you get back.
So please try it out.
Thank you so much, Hannah.
We have time for
a few questions,
so I'll take them
from Slido again.
If you have questions
to ask Hannah at slido,
the event ID is inspire.
Inspire so we have a few here.
Do you have any resources
or recommendations
for folks who want to learn
about censored regression
in general?
So for one,
Emily, I forgot the last name.
Zabor yes, Thank you.
zabormetrics is, I
think, the Twitter handle.
She has an introduction
that is really good.
I like that as a blog post,
if you are more on the type
that
you want a textbook, risk
regression modeling is probably
good.
I'll tweet those out afterwards.
Do we have some tidymodels
resources for the censored
regression stuff? Not about
learning survival analysis
per se.
There's examples out
on the censored homepage.
The URL is up there.
How you can use
all of the models,
but it doesn't cover the theory.
Step this way.
Are there plans to support
competing risk regressions?
Down the line?
Probably, Yes.
So that is a thing that has
been mentioned several times.
So it is definitely
on our radar.
Are there plans to support
random forest backends
like ranger?
So ranger is not yet
in there, but one
of the two that are sort
of going to come next.
Of the engines.
Yeah. So there was
a question about
is censored able to work
with workflow objects.
I would expand that
further as is censored
able to work with tidymodels
as an ecosystem in general.
As like all aspects
of the ecosystem?
Not yet.
I am still having
some work to do.
You can use it with
workflow objects.
You just have to not
push the formula to it,
but rather the variables
and specify the formula
as a sort of engine argument.
I'll put a vignette on that
online. Maybe one more question.
What is the difference between
stratifying - uh, that disappeared?
What is the difference
between stratifying
on a variable in
the survival model
and using that variable
as a predictor?
So stratification in a Cox
model gives you the idea
that the baseline hazard is
different between groups.
And that's sort of the
non-parametric part,
the baseline and your predictors
are the parametric part
that modulate it.
And if you think that this
baseline hazard is not
proportional between groups but
rather fundamentally different
than you would put that
in the stratification.
All right, let's give Hannah
another round of applause.